promettait d'être la mairesse de
la mobilité. Quatre ans plus
tard, qu'en est-il? Mathieu
Prost.
En 2017... lors de la dernière
♪ ♪ ♪
- Le déploiement du Réseau
express vélo, c'est l'un
des legs les plus visibles
en terme de mobilité.
Il a notamment transformé
le visage de la rue Saint-Denis.
Mais les aménagements cyclables,
surtout pendant la pandémie,
ont fait beaucoup de mécontents.
Un record de 300 plaintes, c'est
ce qu'a enregistré le Bureau de
l'ombudsman entre mai et octobre
2020. Et il a souligné plusieurs
manquements, que ce soit
en termes d'accessibilité
universelle, de participation
citoyenne, d'information mais
aussi de sécurité des autres
usagers.
- C'était risqué de lancer
la ligne rose dans la campagne
électorale, mais il se trouve
que les gens ont envie
d'en entendre parler
et qu'ils en rêvent.
- Un lien éventuel entre Lachine
et le centre-ville, c'est tout
ce qu'il reste du projet de
ligne rose de 2017. Il y a bien
eu un bureau de projet et
un budget d'environ 1 million $
qui y était consacré, mais c'est
le REM de l'Est qui devrait
désenclaver les quartiers visés
par la ligne rose.
♪ ♪ ♪
Quant à la gestion des
chantiers, l'un des engagements
phares de la dernière campagne,
une Escouade mobilité a été mise
sur pied pour éliminer les
entraves à la circulation jugées
sauvages. L'année dernière,
elle est intervenue en moyenne
100 fois par jour, 6000 constats
d'infraction ont été remis.
♪ ♪ ♪
Mais le casse-tête de
la circulation reste à peu près
le même. La Ville rappelle,
dès qu'elle en a l'occasion,
que seul un chantier sur quatre
est sous sa juri